Congratulations, you've
finished the course.
Hopefully, you've made some
interesting discoveries about
the New York subway data.
At this point,
you know how to go through the data
analysis process from start to finish.
And you can use NumPy's and Pandas to
write data analysis code that's clean,
concise, and runs quickly.
Great job.
I hope you've enjoyed taking this course
as much as I enjoyed creating it.
I want to hear your thoughts.
Please write a forum post sharing what
were your favorite parts of the course
and what suggestions do you have for
how to improve it.
And by the way for
some extra fun check out the pandas
links in the instructor notes.